大家好 我是[来源标识已去除] 欢迎大家来到[来源标识已去除]出品的拼多多商家成长训练营的第二节课程 权重的算法逻辑
这节课程里面呢 一共有四个板块的内容 第一个呢 叫权重的定义
很多的薪水商家或者刚刚入门的或者是工厂转型来做电商的人根本就不明白权重两个字到底是什么
只能理解说 我的权重不够 我需要加出价 我的权重够了 我可以去优化直动车
我的权重怎么去进行拉伸 其实你可以在拼多多里面思考一个问题
什么一个问题呢 就是权重这个东西在你目前所认知的过程当中
或者你的知识点对权重去进行解释的过程当中 权重到底有没有天花板
就是天花板是什么意思呢 这个地方我给大家去进行解释一下
用最通俗一种的话给大家去进行讲 你可以理解为拼多多的权重
约等于你这条链接在某一个特定时间段内所获取到的订单量
或者是所有的量率的模型 什么一个逻辑
为什么是会说在特定的时间段内 因为拼多多到今天为止
所有的权重的算法都是黑核机制
它从来不会对外公布和别的平台完全不一样
我这个产品到底是一天得到了100单的权重大
还是三天得到了100单的权重高
还是十天的时间得到了1000单的权重高
这个看似每天都是100单
那么请问我的权重哪一个高
那么这个地方就会遇到大家问的一个问题
我哪一个权重高
其实这个地方权重高和低
只是会根据我们这些人在运营过程当中所积累到的实操经验
并不是说我告诉你的权重高
它就一定是对的
实操经验讲完之后呢
会用数据去进行表明我的权重够了
举例
我的产品啊
连续15天左右
每天能消耗2000元的直通车
每天能产生300单的订单啊
我的RY现在是多少呢
我的RY现在是5
这个时候我在第16天的时候
我把我5的RY调到了5.1
哎 我再继续消耗了2000元
还是300单
那么我得到的投产是5.1
那么这个时候你可以理解为
哎 这个时候我调直通车的动作是对的
我的直通车权重累积是对的
我的链接权重累积是对的
所以权重有高有低
但是权重有没有绝对的高和绝对的低
这个是没有一个很明确的答案的
因为拼多多不会告诉你具体的权重算法是什么
所以很多人刚刚入行的时候会说权重的问题
就是高还是低
所以你可以换你理解成你的订单量高还是低
那么在日常累积的过程当中呢
一天的三天的五天的七天的十五天的都可以去进行做
就像上一节课里面跟大家去进行聊的一个问题
我们的评分差为什么我还有订单
因为我和同行去比
相反权重也是一样
那么我跟大家解释完一遍之后呢
你再回来思考一下权重是否有天花板
其实很明确的告诉你
在拼多多里面权重是没有天花板的
但是呢根据我们的操作经验
以及拼多多这个平台里面罚款的尿性
还是建议大家在一个店铺里面达到极限盈利的时候
放弃你权重二次提升的可能
因为你可能会出现各种意外
毕竟我们来这个平台里面是做生意且盈利的
所以了解完这些动作完之后呢
我用一个非常官方的话术给大家去进行
解释一下权重到底是什么
就是产品阶段内积累到的订单量，GMA组成的人群画像
去撬动更多的目标人群
通过订单，GMA累积产生的标签
也就是我刚刚跟大家就说的
权重约等于订单
其实这个地方
订单乘以客单约等于GMA是一个逻辑
是阶段内所积累的
这个阶段我们有的人会告诉你
三天之后调车五天之后调车
七天之后调车
这个是根据我们的经验去进行优化的
根据数据表现的结果去进行优化的
没有一个很明确的答案
这个地方去提到个东西
有的人在网上胡说八道
你这个直通车今天开两千块钱
明天就可以把三的投展调到三零一
我告诉你
这个是没有任何数据依据的
你得看一下你的市场是什么样子
你的对标是什么样子
你的同行是什么样子
你的点击转化曝光是上升还是平稳还是下滑
所以它是阶段不一样所运用到
应用到的权重的解释它也是不一样的
那么第二句话呢
就是组成的人群画像去撬动更多的目标人群
是什么呢
就像我上一节课跟大家去讲
整个权重的逻辑里面会提到一个东西
就是你这款产品叫A产生了300单
那么300单这个里面呢
可能会有3000块钱的GMOV
这个只是数据层面
那么产生订单的这个人里面呢
可能会有18岁的20岁的25
25岁的男性还是女性
他们的收获地址是城市级别是一级城市
还是二级城市还是三级城市
是小区还是学校
还是宿舍
好 在这边跟大家最近解释一下
那么可能就明白了
请问宝妈的转化人群高
还是学生的转化人群高
你们肯定会告诉我
一定是宝妈的转化人群高
但是他的购买周期可能会变长
为什么
因为宝妈比较挑嘛
那么你们就想过一个问题
有没有一种可能
18到25岁的人
既是学生的人群
又是宝妈的人群
因为有的人可能在上学
有的人可能已经结婚生子
所以这个地方的人群
它是一个模糊的概念
它没有一个很准确的概念
我们只要知道一个东西
我这个产品在多少天累积累到了多少订单
组成的GMAV
我再去进行优化直动车的时候
我的直动车可能更容易
就是我们经常会说一句话
就是我直播的时候也经常会说一句话
上课的时候也经常会说一句话
就是我调直动车为什么会断牛
就是你权重积累不够
或者说你调到幅度过大
只有这两个原因
没有什么第三个原因
那么评分这些东西它只是一个基本要素
它不是必要的一个因素
那么再举个例子跟大家去听
还是上一节课程里面的例子
我的产品叫A
15天左右的时间
我每天都烧3000块钱的消耗
然后我每天产生300单
那么你去想过一个问题
从第一天开始的时候
你就能烧到3000吗
你不一定
你可能到第10天左右的时候
你只能消耗到2000
但是你会发现一个问题
还有一个核心
叫出价
我这个地方的出价可能是3的ROI
我到这里的时候
我的出价可能是3.1的ROI
也有可能是2.8的ROI
也就是用数据去进行证明的时候
我的ROI是3
我的限额是1000元
我的投放时长
就是我每天烧1000块钱
我可能是24小时
这是第一天
那我第二天的时候
可能还是24小时
这是第二天
可能到了某第10天的时候
我可能就是18个小时就烧完了
那我1000块钱就烧完了
那我可不可以理解为
第11天的时候
我可以把我的限额提到1200
这个就是在整个直动车底层逻辑里面的
限额递增
降价
找出价
拉权重
拉订单
拉接盟威
这个其实就可以换过来去进行理解
那么了解完
权重定义完之后呢
那么权重到底有没有标准的一个算法呢
有的
虽然拼多多官方不公布
但是整个电商发展了这么多年
我们在日常的运营的过程当中
或者是我们在理解权重的过程当中
或者说我们在拉权重的过程当中
它有个标准化的计算公式
叫量率 时间 入口 以及综合评分
这个地方呢
我用很快速的一句话告诉大家
先有量 才有率
记清楚这句话
有的人会说
我刚开车的时候
我的直通车的点击率很高
转化率很高
那么我想问一下
你的直通车的点击率很高
10就高吗
20就高吗
50就高吗
不一定
看你和谁比
和你的同行比
但是拼多多是屏蔽了所有同行的数据
这是第一个点
第二个点
为什么会说先有量 才有率
两个产品给大家去进行举个例子
你们就明白了
第一个产品和第二个产品
卖一模一样的东西
A产品呢
它的转化率50%
它的点击率50%
好
B产品呢
它的点击率10%
转化率10%
这个是转化
这个是点击
那么这个时候你会面临一个问题
就是有没有一种可能
点击率50%
我今天是10个访客
进来了5个人
他也是50%的转化率
20个访客进来了10个人
进来了10个人
他也是50%的点击率
好
那么这个时候呢
50%的转化率我卖了5单
记住啊
我卖了5单
下面的这个时候呢
有一个很核心的东西出现了
点击率10%
那么有没有一种可能
我这个地方是
1万个访客
我有一千个点击
我最终卖了多少单呢
我有10%的转化
我卖了100单
那么请问谁的权重高
这个呢就是很明显的一个对比
所以在拼多多的整个的链接的粗始数据的权重计算里面
核心的问题点是
你先通过某种手段给我去进行蓝量
而不是先去蓝绿
很多人上去之后会观察
哎呀我的点击率很高
我的转化率很高
我的图片很牛逼
就是你们整个直东之后台的时候
会去来一些轮波图
有的轮波图
主图呢可能只有5%的点击率
5%的转化率
然后下面有一张图
50%的点击率
50%的转化率
哇我一看很牛逼
非常牛逼
那么我想问一下
他所获取到的曝光点击是多少
从量去进行出发
所以他得有一个参考的依据
所以这一点呢
大家一定要去明白
在权重的算法里面
量大局一切
有了量的前提
才会有这款产品的率
两个点击
四个曝光
成交一单
都是50%
一单
另外一个
一万个曝光
一千个点击
或者说我
一百个点击
我1%的点击率
2%的转化率
我跟你50%比我肯定差很多
但是呢
我一天在卖10单
我的权重自然而然就比你高
所以又提了个东西叫时间
时间你可以理解为
一天
三天 七天
十四天
以及一个月
入口是什么呢
就是我刚刚在第一节课程里面跟大家去讲到的
关于主要来源
必要来源和部分来源里面
非常重要的东西叫营销活动的加权
因为营销活动的加权
是对我们产品人群的二次的一个筛权
以及拼多多现在又提出了一个东西
品质化
就是评分
所以整个量率的模型里面的量
我们要知道
量大于一切
那么影响量的因素又有哪些呢
曝光点击成交
那么我怎么去通过哪些手段
能把我的曝光量点击量成交量提高呢
我们就会跟大家去讲几个核心的东西
广告的出价
链接的权重
活动的流量
以及违规的一个限制
比如说广告的出价
出价越高
所获取的曝光量越大
当然它的权重可能就越高
第二个链接的权重
链接的真实的坑产
真实的销售
链接的评分以及店铺的评分
以及活动流量，大速秒杀百亿九块九
对这条链接的加持
以及最后你的链接
没有拼多多现在违规检测
标准化链接的一些东西
什么低价引流违规
分类错误
虚假宣传
标题违规等等等等这些东西
所以我们在日常的过程当中
我们只要记住一个东西
你是通过什么样的方式
去提高你的量
那么在点睛
点睛量的这个板块里面
都知道了曝光
我提高出价
维护好评分
我上活动
我不要有违规
这个只是解决别人能看到你的产品
那别人看到了
他不一定会点击进去
那么点击量的提升是哪些东西呢
有的人会说我把点击率提升
别给我扯肚子
点击率的提升是率的方向
只有有量才行
比如说我轮波图做的很漂亮
因为轮波图做的很漂亮
它也是你直动车的图
你在搜索里面的时候
它会展现
在推荐的时候里面也会展现
外露的价格都是卖这个笔的
一模一样的主图
一模一样的图片
标题什么都是一模一样
它三块
我两块八
我的点击率可能天生就比它高
那么相反我的点击量
天生可能就会比它高
在曝光量相同的情况下
那么再往下面去走
基础信息
销量评价等等
拼多多现在还会有一些标签
什么明日打销量十万加
多少人在拼单
多少人加购
前面有一个满检平台补贴
等等等等这些基础性的标签
它会给你去进行加权
相反还有个东西叫人群精准
就是宝妈的用户和学生的用户
年龄重叠
但是随着转化能力更高
转化能力越高或者点击能力越高
我相反我的量也会提交上去
所以你们从这些方面去进行
优化你的量力模型
最后就是成交价格
图文以及真实的一个评价
都会影响你的转化能力
所以讲到这里的时候会发现一个问题
我在讲绿
但是绿呢又不是最重要的
相反的绿也非常非常的重要
因为有了量的前提
才会有绿这个轨东西出现
好再往下面去走
绿就简单了
所以绿的提升和量的提升
它们的渠道其实是一样的
最后呢它的核心是什么
它的核心其实是付费的出价
能解决很大曝光量的问题
第二个
图片的优秀
是可以解决很高点击量的问题
第三个
活动的加权
是可以解决人群包更加精准的问题
最后人群精准
是可以解决你整个转化能力
订单量提升的一个问题
所以提高权重的四个核心逻辑
出价
图片
活动
人群
好
那么最后呢
又会提到一个东西
就是一直在去说活动加权
活动加权
那么在活动加权
里面到底是哪些活动比较牛逼呢
好给大家去做了一个排序
叫一二三级活动的流量入口
提到这个地方的时候呢
就给大家去穿插一个小小的一个东西
就是如果说你们想在拼多多里面长期做一家好店
银利的店
长期发展
在拼多多里面长期发展
不要谈什么3.5年的目标
去想一个
今年一年
我怎么在拼多多里面活下去
企业活得不错
就是建议大家
尽可能的去做一个品牌的
旗舰店
加权是比较多的
那么一级入口是什么呢
百亿加万人团
这就是一级入口
也是拼多多量最大的地方
这就是为什么很多人来找[来源标识已去除]
说我是工厂
我们今年做到了300万
500万
1000万
走的一个指标
你们有没有什么陪跑的项目
顾问的项目
我们想把我们的品牌变成黑标
其实他并不是想要把他的品牌变成黑标
是想让他的产品上百亿
因为自主品牌的黑标
自主品牌的百亿
它里面有什么东西
直动车不比价
有自主定价权
当然我们公司提供这样的顾问服务
[来源标识已去除]亲自带
如果你们有兴趣的
可以咨询一下我们的班主任
是因为我上了直动车之后
我去优化我的直动车的时候
我的直动车不比价
我的产品不比价
当然前级条件是评分
OK的情况下
那么再往下面就准呢
就二级权重
就是单坑秒杀
那单坑秒杀里面可能会有很多很多的一个入口
有的人会说什么584呀
还有什么品类呀
等等等等这些只要挂刷二秒杀都要
它都是属于二级权重
甚至说2260就可以理解为是
最后呢一个三级权重就是
9块9大促
限量，级裸价
裸价就可以理解为
它几乎没有太多的一个东西了
一般都打弱付费和低价的人用裸价用的比较多
所以拼多多里面整个营销活动的加权
其实分车是非常非常的细的
所以你们听到现在还以为拼多多只是一个
开个店上一条链接开车就有订单的一个平台吗
是 答案是对的
但是它不一定引力
你得精细化的
你得想一下整个平台里面的入口
权重，标签，人群，百亿，秒杀，九块九
等等等等这些东西
所以我这个地方呢
讲到这里的时候呢
送给大家一句话
就是在当下的整个拼多多里面
你了解到了它的整个流量的一个模型
以及权重的一个算法的时候呢
你记清楚[来源标识已去除]送你的一个核心
就是产品的起点
决定了产品的终点
什么意思呢
就是你这个产品上去玩强付费
你就应该想尽一切办法
从强付费的角度去提升这款产品的权重
你如果玩节牛
你就应该去做节牛的角度去提升
你如果玩百亿
玩黑标
打品牌
做外人团
你就应该从这些角度去进行出发
所以产品的起点
并不是说我从弱付费变成强付费
强付费变成节牛
不要去做这种
拖了裤子放屁多此一举的事情
完完全全没有必要
因为你不要把拼多多这个平台
当成一个傻子平台
它能这么多年做到国内电商图文
货架板块
我认为是一哥的
它里面实际是有一些门道的
并且呢
它的权重算法以及流量推荐的逻辑
全部是黑盒
我这两节课程跟大家更多的讲的是
我这几年在拼多多里面的一些经验
以及平台给到了一些数据
给我们的做的一些数据的个反馈
其实是希望你们认认真真去听的
好
那么这一节课程呢
就跟大家去讲到这里
祝大家天天报答